can you can you just re-emphasize one of
the points you puberty just can't stop
like it's a movie right it doesn't it
doesn't work that way it's a it's a
healthy process in the human body and um
as you heard from Scott Nugent who's the
that's a trans
uh a woman who transitions to a male
although she says in the film she's one
of the only honest people we talk to and
she says I transitioned to appear like a
man but I'll never be a man anyways we
hear from from her that uh there are no
studies that have been done on this
whatsoever we've never we've never had a
generation of kids
that hasn't had this done to them like
they're Lab Rats so we're just kind of
trying this out on a whole generation of
kids but based on what we do know we
know that these these are serious drugs
a little bit later in that same
interaction
um we talk about what the actual drug is
the actual puberty blocking drug is
Lupron that's what it's called
and it is used off label to quote block
puberty it is actually a cancer drug for
prostate cancer that you give to adult
men
and at a certain point they realize they
had chemical castration properties so
they started giving it to sex offenders
to chemically castrate pedophiles and
now we give it to 12 year old boys
and I asked that pediatrician about that
said Lupron that's chemical castration
and that's when she said she wanted to
get up and the interview was going to be
over
she didn't want to talk about it but
it's absolutely true and this is what
we're doing not just to a couple of kids
but to thousands millions of kids yeah
so that the question is also how
widespread is this right we know the
pharmaceutical industry has done such
damage to our country especially over
the last couple of years and you want to
look at kind of one of the major
enlightenments is how people don't trust
Pfizer AstraZeneca Johnson and Johnson
and moderna anymore
um after the damage they've done but
this is an interesting wrinkle where
people don't realize it's not just the
pharmaceutical companies that are
pushing antidepressants on you
unnecessarily and by the way they might
make your depression anxiety worse just
so we're clear so be very careful before
you go on benzodiazepines or Prozac or
xanax but it's not just that but the
pharmaceutical Industries involved in
this trans issue there's billions of
dollars to be made in new FDA approved
puberty blockers and then with it the
benzodiazepines and these other drugs
that could also accompany it talk about
the pharmaceutical profit motive
involved in a lot of this well as you
just said Billy millions of dollars and
anytime there's billions of dollars
involved then uh we we know that that's
that's reason enough for skepticism when
it comes to chemically castrating kids
that should be that should be the entire
reason that you need to be skeptical of
it but there are people that are making
billions of dollars and it's not just
the pharmaceutical industry this this
goes to
um therapists you know there are
therapists that used to just be regular
old therapists and then they realize
that the real money is in the gender
affirming game
um and that's where you can really make
the money that's where you can find all
the clients and so this is all they do
now is they do gender affirming
um uh care and then there there are you
know endocrinologists who this is all
they do now is give out the hormone
blockers and everything there there are
people who have realized in therapies
like psychiatric industry the
pharmaceutical industry the medical
industry generally that there is lots of
money to be made here and um so they
have no incentive
you know if uh if if you've got a
five-year-old boy
who has now had this gender confusion
placed on him there's no profit
incentive in helping that child overcome
the confusion and just live as a boy
I mean that that boy there's a dollar
sign over his head that boy is worth
millions of dollars in the long run to
lots of very powerful Industries